soral un bon soir c'est bien connu le
cardinal turcotte des interviews et à
maintes reprises il était très
identifiée à montréal il a passé une
cinquantaine d'années oui oui dans un
poste quand même importante si vous
considérez le fait qui a été a été nommé
évêque auxiliaire au début des années 80
et qu'il était quand même archevêque
émérite à la toute fin
ça fait pas mal tout près de 30 ans oui
était très identifiée à montréal 13
identifiés et c'est l'humain qui me l'a
raconté à la blague il trouvait que les
gens l'identifier beaucoup au tribe les
expos beaucoup aux canadiens de montréal
mais c'était un homme d'église
on pouvait pas l'oublier mais une église
située dans un québec
dans toutes ces années là qui a
tellement changé vous allez voir au
début des années 80 le jeune évêque
auxiliaire de montréal jean claude
turcotte reçoit le mandat d'organiser
une portion du voyage de jean-paul ii
l'événement est colossal et contre toute
attente des dizaines de milliers de
québécois sont dans les rues pour
accueillir le pape
je pense que c'était en 84 sûrement
l'événement majeur ici
nous ne voulons pas
pour un moment on pourrait croire à la
résurrection de l'église mais ce n'est
qu'une illusion
l'église à laquelle jean claude turcotte
n'étant ne cessera de perdre du terrain
dans une société en pleine mutation
la contraception l'avortement le mariage
homosexuel toutes les questions qui
touchent les moeurs vont demeurer de
profonds litige entre l'église et la
société québécoise et l'église est
laissée à elle même si elle veut
évangéliser les enfants québécois
elle devra le faire sans l'aide du
système scolaire qui se dé confessionnal
is
et puis le cardinal turcotte doit gérer
une des croissances spectaculaires
depuis 2003 au québec toutes traditions
confondues 440 églises ont été fermés
vendus ou détruites
le patrimoine religieux est un joyau que
l'église ne peut plus payer
nous sommes rendus pas loin du bout du
rouleau
nous ne pourrons pas continuer sans
l'aide de l'état
voici le cardinal jean claude turcotte
et regards fruitiers
le cardinal est charismatique
particulièrement aimé de ses fidèles et
c'est un homme de foi le mystère de la
foi je vous avoue que moi c'est un des
grands mystères et s'échelonnent des
questions je leur pose à dieu quand je
le verrai il a marqué son époque mais
c'est la société québécoise qui semble
tourner le dos à la religion le monde
autour du cardinal a bien changé il a dû
gérer on l'oubli mais il fut une époque
pas si lointaine que ça où l'église
catholique était commandé terriblement
ostentatoire elle était même on pourrait
dire envahissante
elle avait un langage parfois hautain il
avait des gestes des symboles qui était
vraiment au delà de la population et
voilà qu'arrive quelques pendant les
années 80 est parti à ma partir de 1990
un homme qui tient un langage tout
simple qui a pas peur des foules qui a
pas peur de ses opinions et qui
s'exprime publiquement
je pense qu'une partie la réponse se
trouve là mais c'était pas un homme de
changement en par ailleurs il était
proche des gens on l'a dit on l'a
et aujourd'hui ce pas là le changement
c'est un homme d'église consommateurs
n'oubliez pas qu'ils travaillent ils
travaillaient pour une cause celle de
jésus je veux bien mais aussi pour
l'église catholique
or dans l'église catholique qui a mené
hier archi et non seulement il était
archevêque de montréal
il était aussi cardinal donc assez
proche de l'autorité dans un rôle comme
celui là par des vous parce qu'il prend
exactement contraire de ce que le
vatican veut par exemple sur les
questions de l'avortement ou sur une
foule d'autres questions aussi
alors quel sera son héritage qu'est-ce
qu'il va laisser j'ai fait un parallèle
qui va peut-être vous étonner mais ce
tir et c'est plus qu'on peut dire c'est
l'héritage qui va avoir laissé après
toutes ces années de travail acharné au
vatican
souvent dans l'ombre ce sera
probablement le fait qu'il a démissionné
il a ouvert la porte à la papauté aux
gens dans la papauté qui voudraient bien
ou qui voudraient partir à manama
c'est pas un héritage banal je dirais
que jean claude turcotte est en train de
nous dire que on peut être achevé d'une
ville d'une ville comme montréal être
dans une situation parfois de conflit ou
de contradiction
vous pouvez aussi être cardinal et avoir
un langage toussaint parler aux gens de
manière toute simple et réussir à faire
des potes dans sa salle il s'est
peut-être la meilleure manière pour lui
de défendre ce qu'il avait de plus
précieux son héritage sa foi alain
crevier vous avez une grosse journée
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous et pour en savoir plus sur la
vie et sur l'héritage justement de jean
claude turcotte je vous invite à
consulter notre dossier web vous voyez
l'adresse en ce moment à l'écran